The joe rogan experience
but never got injured.
Even if he did, he wouldn't know.
What does that guy doing these days?
I have no clue.
I know he wrote a book.
It was the last time we handle on the
inside of way. Oh, you guys had them on?
Yeah. I mean that's five years ago. That
guy, my guy was a fucking character.
I mean if it wasn't for
guys like tank Abbott,
I mean there would have
been no early days. Yeah.
You know you needed a guy
looked at identify with him.
A lot of these crazy guys out there. Shoe.
You can do what? I can do this. Yeah,
that's what you need. Yeah. I had a giant
bell in. You would knock people dead.
Yeah. He was like a Roy
Nelson only with no stamina.
Yeah. Well and and and no black belt
tech. No black belt in Jiu Jitsu. Yeah.
Well Roy Nelson is a fucking
complete anomaly. Yeah, he is.
Looks like if you lose weight,
how is it possible that he trains so hard?
I've seen this guy throw world
like 130 155 pound kettle bells,
like one arm swings. We can wing being
like, it's nothing. You would lose weight,
right?
You would think,
but he would be a 185
pound phenom instead.
He's a heavyweight.
He's a cubic contender and maybe it's an
implant in the belly that he just wants
to do that because the Buddha belly
implants kick them and he didn't even feel
it. He's aware a chess pad.
He imagined someone did that.
I mean if girls get fake boobs,
let's think about this cause girls
do get fake boobs and they fight.
You know girls have got it. I want
to mention any names, but we seen it.
Girls have had no boobs and all
of a sudden they have boobs.
You can get fake boobs and still fight.
But what about a fake belly?
What about a guy who says, I just like,
oh, I like a belly. I like looking good.
You know, if, if a guy had a fake belly,
I was going to try to see if
we're going to hit it to the back.
I'll say I'll make a
hunchback out of them.
See if you can move the battle all the
way to the back. Way To hook to the back.
Lower back. We never had
one like that, you know,
I mean the hunchback from not
are dumb. That's a high, but no,
you never saw a hundred beck from
the bottom right. Like lower back.
We can make that like a lumbar pad.
Work as a lumberjack.
Yeah. Sleeps all night.
Then he works all day. Like
if, if you look at Roy Nelson,
he's like the size of a really
good middleweight. Yeah, no he is.
Yeah.
But meanwhile the guy knocked out,
Chuck Congo knocked out Brendan Shab
knocked out some big fucking heavyweights.
Knocked out mitre own.
I mean fucking knocked out
a lot of people. Staples.
Troover right. That'll show,
did he knock out seven?
I do not remember that
fight. Wow. Um, and it does.
The worst thing is it's
with his right hand.
So you were thinking that people
going to the hill to left up,
but somehow he connects
anyway with the arm bars.
You know what's going to happen? We can
stop it. No, almost knocked down over him.
Remember that? Yeah, he heard
over him. Yup. True. Back home.
Jesus Christ. Crazy. Yeah. I
mean, Roy is like six feet tall.
Stephan's true. Seven feet tall.
Yeah. I mean fucking animal.
Roy is an animal and I honestly,
I mean look at his gut right there.
How much does that, he weighs
about two 50. Right? He's, he,
I'm not bullshitting.
Yep.
He is 50 pounds overweight and
he's a world class athlete.
I mean, you cannot say the Roy
Nelson is not a world class fighter.
He's absolutely a world class fighter
and he's 50 pounds overweight.
So you dropped down 50 pounds. Now you're
200 pounds, you make 85. You cut weight.
Everybody does that. Cut 15 pounds. You're
85. You're a world champion. You know,
there's not a butter bean. You
know, we were somewhere, uh,
and the letter commissioner taught
me from all the boxes on the cart.
He had actually the best blood
pressure and cholesterol for, for real.
He said we were a shock that the
guy is in the phenomenal shape.
That's what he told us. Yeah. That's
insane. Butter being made him look like,
yeah, you're Rodriguez. Look at
him. Jesus Christ. I actually,
it looks good here is the whole family
is going to look exactly like that.
I hear go upper right hand corner.
Yeah.
That's what he looked like when
he was at its worse. Meanwhile,
he's another guy knocked dude's dead man.
He is so funny.
That's such a good time with him and
[inaudible] Prince George in Canada.
He was there. He's a player. Oh yeah.
That's hilarious. Very
funny guy. That's funny.
You know he's a fucking hell of a cook.
Apparently
you can't tell,
but it like there's was watched a video
of butter being cooking some ribs and I
was like, damn, that looks legit. Like a
smoker. Who was cooking them in a smoker?
He broke the rule though.
Don't get high if you're on supply.
Okay.